そこで自分が発見した仮説のあれだそうだからによって解脱にラベルつけてるだけ
別に解脱は違う三つ解脱あるわけじゃないんです
そこでラベリングなんですけど
この空見えた人はアッパネという
無常見えた人は無願解脱であって
不見えた人 苦見えた人が無常解脱というし
無我見えた人の場合は苦解脱と呼んで
順番逆になるわけ ですから
順番逆に置き換えて見てください
普通の順番というのは無常
苦 無我なんですね 解脱の場合は苦解脱
無常解脱 無願解脱 無常に苦解脱ではないんです
無我に苦解脱 お釈迦様に聞いた方がいいと思います
また 解説は長く長い解説はありますけど
今日はできません で 次にヴィモッカムカ
解脱門 また同じことなんですね
何を発見して解脱したかということで
また同じことでスンニャターヌパッターナ
全ては苦であると観察して悟ったんだと
あるいは全ては無常であると類観して悟ったんだと
あるいは全ては無願類観して悟ったんだと
いわゆるわかりやすく言えば
全ては無我であると悟ったらスンニャターヌパッターナですね
全ては苦であると悟ったらアニッリッターヌパッターナ
無常解脱の道ですね で
全ては無常ですよとわかりましたら無願解脱ですね
で そこでヴィパッサナーの世界は一応これぐらいのことで終わっちゃうんです
瞑想のこと それからこの七段階目の清らかな一経地の説明をしなきゃいけないんです
で できるだけ表でわかりやすく言うとだけど
まああの どれだけできるだけ説明します
まとまったら結構一回になる可能性ありますけど
で 結構あの それからまあ本当は説明するのもったいないと思いますけど
で またいろいろ異論もありますし
まあ一応浄土論のとこはね
まあ立ち入らないでアビダンマの部分だけ
できるだけ狭くして説明しようと思います
で 番目はこの清らかなステージ
とにかく心が清らかになっていく
で 上のレベルはあのレベルね
また後でだべっちゃいますけど
一番目は戒 戒定慧 戒定慧は別に説明しなくてもよろしいことで
戒律のことで 何かやるためには
やっぱり人間には最初にいろいろ決まり
規律 規則というものはあるということで
人間っていうのはもう生き方も決めてないと
他人に悪口ばっかり言ってるんだと
悪いことばっかりしてるんだと
それぐらいの自己コントロールない人にはもう何の見込みもないんですね
ですから 人は道徳的に正しいっていうのは
もう基本の基本なんです
だから仏教のヴィパッサナー世界から見ればすごいことじゃないんです
そんな戒律ってのは基本の基本なんです
当たり前のことではない
仏教だけではなく 他の宗教でもいろいろ戒律があるんですね
戒律というのは では我々のこの口と体の行動をコントロールしてくれるんですね
悪いことを言いたいんだけど
言わないでコントロールする
悪いことしたいんだけど
しないで自分をコントロールする
それぐらいの当たり前のことなんですね
だからといって 仏教ではこの戒律学は膨大な量
それでもあります 三蔵経の一つは戒律だから
本は五冊ですね それまたすごくアビダンマと同じくものすごい厚い本五冊なんですね
まあ法律のテキストみたいに
行単位で行単位で行単位で
人々の生き方に対していろんなことを言っているんですね
どんたくさん言っても
お釈迦様はそんなに人々を戒律で縛って縛っておいて
いじめようと思ってなかったんです
ですから 最初はお釈迦様は戒律を教えてなかったんです
ほとんどこの戒律を始めたのはもう四十年経ったところでそうですね
二十年かな もう二十年ぐらい経ったところですね
ということはどういうことでしょうかね
やっぱり仏教を聞くために
お釈迦様から真理を知りたいと聞いた人々は
みんな立派な方々でした
もともと 欲できた 欲ない
欲がない 世俗的なことでもう倒産したんだから
まあ宗教でもやって金儲けしようとかね
そういう風なこの気持ちで来たわけじゃないんですね
[背景の音楽]子供はしょっちゅう病気になりますから
じゃあ宗教に入りますよとかね
そういう普通の世界のレベルではなかったんで
お釈迦様に会った人々はみんなすっごい尊くて
ひっそり哲学者たちで
森林たちで真面目な人たちで
鋭い知恵を持っている
だからお釈迦様の一言葉で
一言葉でもう信じわかってしまうんですね
お釈迦様に会ったのは
この権力から破ることだけなんですね
生き方 正しく生きてなさいと
嘘を言うなというそこではなかったんですよ
これもう四十年 五十年も修行して
山の中からずっと山の中で生活していて
降りてきた人だから 話を聞いて誘った人がいるんだと
本人がもう世界離れて山の中に隠れていたのに
やっぱり誘った人が街の真ん中に生活しているんだと話を聞いて
そこで街に出かけてみたんだから
だからあなたは行儀よく振る舞いなさいという
そんな意味もないんです
大仏は元々はなかったんですね
でもどんどん社会の中にいるんだから
社会の人々はね いろいろ入っちゃうでしょうね
前 例えで言ったように
このよくインドであったことはね
財産がなくなったら 倒産してから入ってきちゃった
ベンゼン病とかいろんなことで親戚みんな亡くなってしまったら
病気から逃げるためにもう入ってしまった
よくインドにペストとかね
ありましたから なぜならばネズミっていうのは神様でしょ
だから殺さないんですね
そういうことでネズミ殺す権利あるのは一つのカーストの人々だけなんです
その人々はネズミ捕まって殺してもいいんだけど
他の人を殺しちゃったらすごく罰が当たるんです
これ神様の乗り物なんです
だから神様の舌なんですね
それで原子爆弾も作りましたと
あの国はね 考え方あれぐらいなんですけどね
だからインド人もやっぱりインド人だけ生活すれば世界のもの先輩になるのにね
この欲を捨ててしまってね
世の中に平和を教え マハトマガンディーさんもいたよ
強い人は武器を持たないんだと
こんなお金があったって強いわけじゃないんだと
一日で壊れるんだと 世の中見たらわかるでしょうに
もうタイにしても 日本にしても
ヨーロッパにしても もうすっごい金持ちやと思って威張ってるんだけど
これ一日で全財産消えちゃいますからね
ですから それぐらいの哲学はインドにあるでしょうね
だからまあ平和のために我々は武器を持たないと
まだ前のね インディラ・ガンディー時代ではね
もう随分昔 技術を持っていたんだけど
インディラ・ガンディーはそれをやめたんです
やりませんと よくこの適当な考え方の人々がね
まあ腕が良くない人々が出てきたら
まあ今この国は倒れちゃったんだけどね
で まあまた頭の痛いことをやっちゃうんです
だからこの ネズミをもう拝ませてればいいんじゃないかなと思いますけど
ネズミと牛を ネズミに乗る神様が知恵の神様なんです
ジャネーシャ 像には乗れません
知恵の神様 ネズミの背中に乗って旅に出るんです
どんな知恵でしょうかね
像は神の使いじゃないんですね
インドで だから結局私は人間の考え方というのはもう疑い
疑問になるのはそういうこと
像っていうのはインドのこの
軍隊なんでしょ 戦争に行く場合はいつも像に乗って行くんです
だからすごく安全なんですね
馬よりも 怖いものはないんです
像に乗ったら 像は遅いんだから
ということじゃないんで
遅くたっても走ったら完全速いんだけど
でも馬ほどは速くないんですけど
人間を追い越すことはできません
ましましはかまわなくてね
でも馬ほど速くないと思いますけど
でも像はもう何か ぶつかっちゃったら壁でも何でも壊しちゃうし
馬なんか何頭が来たって像が出てきちゃったらみんな逃げちゃいますよ
恐くて そしたら像はそういうことだから困るんですよ
神の使いになったら 神の使いの背中に乗って戦争に出てどうするんですか？だからそこは置いておくんです
で 馬も置いておく 置いておいて
知恵の神様にネズミをあなたネズミに乗っていってください
特別なものをそうするとかもしれない
あなた牛に乗って来てくださいと
結構真面目に信じてるんですね
だから普通に考えてば
偉大なる神別中ならば
これは象は象徴として象に乗ってくるんだと言った方が
あるいは鯨に乗ってくるんだとかね
何か言った方が 怖いものはないと
まあそれはそれで置いといて
とにかく昔は伝染病とかね
ペストとかやって そこで丸ごと村丸ごと死んだりする
そこで一人一人逃げるんですね
逃げる人々はもう誰も当てがないんだだから修習者の方に参り込んだりする
で また欲があったところで
自分の奥さんが浮気しちゃったら男は逃げると
大体その習慣が向こうにあるんです
で 他の国々と違うかもしれませんんだけど
自分の奥さんがもういろいろ浮気したりしてて
ちょっと性格は軽いなと分かったら
男は外に逃げてしまう
何もしない で その場合もそこで引き取ってくれるということがある
スリランカではよくたまにああいうふうにもうなんかもっとひどいことをやるんです
そうやって何か不倫でもして見つかったら
あいつを探すんです 探して開けるんじゃあなた
こそこそとやる必要はないんだと
載せてください そこももうちゃんと警察に届いて
そういうことで そういう人に
渡しますと で 子供は別にご人の場合はやっぱりそこは親だけ見ると
父親に見るか母親に見るか
そこは普通に普通の知識で判断します
時々子供だけは渡さないんだとかもあるし
子供を分けて半分あなたに半分私にということになる場合もあるし
あるいは子供一緒に行ってしまったら
そこでも子供はちょっとそこでいろいろトラブルあるなと思ったら
また返してもらうというのは
そこは普通なんですけど
子供に対する感じはね
あいつに対する感じはなんか
なんか変というかね 他の国からすれば変なんですけどね
私も何人かに会って話したことあるんですね
別に家を出て いろんなところでいろいろ仕事をしたり
お寺に投函して そこで何年も泊まっていたりとかね
あの人結構結婚して子供いた人々なんですね
なんであんた上にいってないんですか？とあまり言わない
もうものすごく一年ぐらい経ったところで
やっと個人的なことを言うぐらいなら言わない
それであの人にすごく厳密にいろいろ絞って絞って聞いたところで
なんか奥さんが何か誰かと隠れて何かできていたんだとかそういうことで
何のことなく出てきた
それだけです 外に出ても誰にも言わない
自由な人のような感じで
何か仕事を見つけて どこで生活し
旅で生活しているという
まあかなり自由 まあ男は男だから自由ですよって自由を味わっているかどうかはわかりませんだけどね
どうせ男は自由でしょうと
オスの方が出かけて出ていけばいいやと
そういう風に思っているかどうかわかりませんだけど
まあ遠い昔でもそういう現状があって
それですっげえそういう風な人々が入ると
このすごい哲学的な修行自体という世界じゃないんだから
やっぱり道徳を欠たりはする
いい加減なことをする
他界の他界だから出家の世界なの
社会の秩序を破ったりもする
仲良くしないようにするということで
どんどん戒律ができてきたんです
それで戒律は一応一般的な戒律は種類でありまして
1番目はパーティノッカサンガリシーラというんですね
パーティノッカサンガリシーラというのは
解脱を確定してくる戒律という意味なんですね
解脱を確定してくる戒律というので
でもこの訳はなかなか分からないんですね
ブッダが頃も解釈してないし
そのこちらはちゃんと訳しています
出家者を解脱させる道具という戒律
その戒律は決まってるんです
お坊さんたちのは項目ごとに決まってるし
在家の方々にも回 回 回とかね
項目は決まってるんですね
それも結局世間的な一般的に守らなくてはいけないこと
嘘言ってはいけない 泥棒してはいけないとかね
そういう戒が その上で自分の生活はちゃんと守ってくれるんですね
誰も攻撃してくれない
誰も余計な根拠のないところで自分を批判したりもしない
疑ったりもしない ですから
安心して修行できる 本人も気持ちいいんですね
悪いことしたことがないんだと
そういう戒律があります
2番目はこのインリヤサンガリシーラ
インリヤサンガリシーラというのは
原因に一心にコントロールするんですね
見たい放題見る 聞きたい放題聞くではなくて
見ても心の中で欲と怒りが生まれないように気をつける
ものを音を聞いても 心の中で欲と怒りが生まれないように
混乱しないようにガードする
その戒律なんです ご飯食べても
その美味しさで欲か怒りが生まれないように心をガードする
心の安定を守る  3番目はアージワパリスッディ
アージワパリスッディというのは生活なんですね
人は何とかして食べて生きなければいけないんですね
家を建ててであろうか
咲いてるであろうかね
もう なんて言いますか
着るもの 食べるもの 住むところと
病気になったら薬というつぐらいが基本的な必要なんですね
そこは在家の方々は仕事をして得るなくちゃいけないんですね
出家の場合はやっぱりかわいそうです
まあ拾って使わなくちゃいけないんですね
まあ拾って使おうということは
やっぱり自然破壊に貢献しないということです
厳密他の戒律で厳密だからね
例えば殺生戒というのは在家の方には殺生しない
それだけで終わりますけど
出家の場合はそんな簡単ではなくて
いろいろもう複雑なんですね
一つの戒律とっても まあそういうことで
出家の人々は拾って食べなさいと
そうするとまあ自然破壊したことにならないんですね
服を綺麗な服を着たくて
いろいろ注文出したり作ったりしちゃうと
やっぱりたくさん自然破壊やら生命破壊につながる
捨てたものだから もうとっくに
もうそれの自然破壊はとっくに終わってるんだからね
そのものを作った使った方が自然に優しくなっちゃうんですね
たくさん食べ物を作って
もうちょっとだけ食べて
みんな平気で捨てちゃうでしょうに
そこはどうせ捨てるもんだから
もう一人の人がいただいて食べた方が
それも自然に優しい態度なんです
まあそういうことで出家は
まあでも出家の場合はこの拾うこと
いわゆる托鉢なんですね
それが出家の仕事なんですね
住人による仕事なんです
在家の方々の自分なりのそれなりの仕事があります
そこは清らかな仕事をしなさいと
出家の場合はもうすごい決まりがある
一種類のことをやってはいけないと
二十一下 十九かな 十九ですね
それ以上いい客だから 二十一番
二十有一あります 在家の場合はこの道具売ったりしてはいけませんし
武器売ったり買ったりしてはいけませんし
毒やらね 悪いもの売ったり買ったりしてはいけませんし
まあ酒とかね 麻薬とか売ったり買ったりしないで
普通の生活でよろしいと
だからまあそこはあまりよくない
あまりではなくて やっぱりお金が綺麗じゃないんだと
人に酒を売って酒を売って金儲かっちゃうんだと
でもお客さんの方が大変でしょうに
買った人がね アル中になったり
家庭崩壊したり 仕事うまくいかなかったり
病気になったりとかね
麻薬売ってもすごく早く金儲かるかもしれませんだけど
使った人々の人生は台無しになるでしょう
ですから お金自体はものすごい汚いんですね
例えば武器やらね いろんな人殺す道具作って売ったらね
ものすごい世界では一番金儲かる仕事です
それは 一つのピストルでもね
作るのはすごい簡単でね
そんなに技術も要りませんし
でもそこを売って これをだから売れるためには品質はいいと紹介しなくちゃいけないでしょうに
だからいかに簡単に人殺されるかっていうことを言わなくちゃいけないんですね
だからそのお金っていうのは全く汚いと
いくら金持ちであろうと
いくら億万長者であろうが
仏教はものすごい汚い
褒めません 金持ちとも言わない
仏教ではほんのちょっとの畑でもやって
そこで半分ぐらい売って
それで米を買って その野菜を食べてる人はすごい金持ち
その人の 一円は あの億万長者のいう人の十億円よりも価値がある
清らかだから だから水の場合も同じでしょうに
で 琵琶湖ぐらいの大きな綺麗な湖にあっても
もし汚染されてるんだったら意味がないでしょうに
ガラスいっぱいに綺麗な水があるんだったら
どんな水が価値があるんですかね
ガラスいっぱいのおっきな水でしょう
ですから量じゃないんです
質なんですね ということで
この生活は清らかにしてくださいと
出家の場合はまた戒律が違いますね
まあ自分がよく真面目に修行しているんだとか
そんなことは言ってはいけません
言ったら ああ あなた本当に修行者だから
じゃあ私は教えますよとか
あるいは人々の個人的な面倒を見てあげたりとかね
人々のメッセージをあちこちに言ってあげたりとか
仲介してあげたりとか
そこで気に入ってもらって
家族の仲間 仲間に入ってもらって
それでお布施をもらうとか
そういうのは正しい生き方ではないんです
それから占ってあげたりとか
で よくやることなんですけど
祈祷とかね 祈祷をやったりとかね
お金もらっちゃいけません
お金ではなくて 食べ物でも何でも
何も収入を得てはいけないんですね
だから治療も禁止なんです
例えばお医者さんが付いてきたってのも治療は禁止ですね
それそれと で 何とかあったら人を助けても構いません
まあ祈祷なんか仏教で認めてないんだけど
祝福はその代わりにありますね
仏法僧の力で祝福しましょうと
その祝福はできますよ
だけど祈祷にはならないんですね
それは信者さんに何か問題があって困ってるんだったら
まあ勝手にやってあげるだけで
あるいは信者さんがお願いしたらやってあげるだけで
それによって偉くはならないようにシステムができてるんです
なぜならば お経をあげて祝福してもらうことは
どんなお坊さんがやったっても同じですよと
はっきりと言ってるんですね
あのお坊さんだからうまくいったという言葉は認めないんです
もしあるお坊さんが やっぱり私がやらなくちゃうまくいくじゃないよと思ったら
その人はそれによってお布施もらったはいけません
そんなこと言ってもいけません
そういうことで この あの
まあ迷信の世の中でありますからね
ですからなかなかあれですし
あの祝福 祝福したっても構いません
だけど それによって収入を得ては
ご飯をしてもらってはいけません
誰かが突然病気になったらとかったら
この緊急を要するとして治療してなんとかしてあげたってもいいんだけど
それも それ以上何もやってはいけません
治療してはいけないっていうことがあった
治療したケースいくつか残ってはいるんですね
昔の偉いお坊様方 お釈迦様の時代です
あるお坊さんがある貧しい家に毎日行ってご飯をもらって食べたりするんだけど
その家にこの女の子が一人いたな
で で 突然この何か霊が乗り移ってしまったんですね
たまに乗り移っちゃうみたいですね
で そのお坊さんがとこへ来て座っていると
いきなりこの子供はおかしくなっちゃって
首が曲がっちゃって こう出てきて倒れちゃったんですね
それでお坊さん見たら
これはまあすぐ分かって
もう阿羅漢でしたけど
これは何とかで まあ分かりませんだけどね
その子の誰々が乗っ取ってるんだ
で  じゃあお坊さん何のことなくね
ご飯をもらってる時代です
それで食べて それで一人食べるぐらいしかいきませんだからそれを絶対食べて
まあ鉢ありますね それにちょっと水を入れてくださいと
水を入れて その洗っちゃう
洗うんですね 洗って これこの子に飲ましなさいと言って
それはそういうのに仕立てた族でしたから
もう断れないんですね
大体阿羅漢っていうのはあんなに体力ありますからね
この聖者じゃないんだから
この世の中に散ってる感じの狂暴なんで
すごい力があるんです
だからこれ飲ましなさいと言ったら
みんな信者さんだから何のことなく俺も飲ましたって
そこできちんともう治って
それっきり治ってしまったと
でもそれでもいろいろ噂になってるわけで
そこでもう そこまでそれ以上は行くなと
ちょっとその家族は悩んでるんだから
次治ったけどだけのこと
で この神通力のね  使ってはいけないと
使ってはいけないと言っても
もうたまにちょっと使ってる場合もあります
それも一つのストーリーでありまして
それまた同じ家庭の また同じ女の子の同じストーリーで
お坊さんが違うお坊さんでしたけども
それでまた大阿羅漢です
大体その家だけ ほとんどその家に行ったり来たりして
ご飯を頂いたりして 家族一員みたいに仕えたりするんですね
で 楽わしに行ったら いろいろアクセサリー売ってる人がいるのに
アクセサリー屋ですか
それからすごい金銀で
もう金銀で この女の子がこれ欲しくて欲しくて
で お母さんに一つ買ってちょうだいかって言ったら
お母さんのお金もう何もないんですね
そしたらもうあなたはね
お金何もないんですよと
だから泣くな 子供は泣き止めないんですね
お坊さんから見ても やっぱり女の子だからやっぱりおしゃれしたいし
やっぱり母親もね 編みたいし
でもお金がなかったらどうしようもないでしょう
そしたらそのちっちゃな子供としゃべって
で 泣いてるんだけど このうちの藁ですか
それでまあ 二 三本ぐらいね
で 持ってきてちょうだいと
持ってきて じゃあこれ編みましょうと
だからお坊さんに言われるんだから
これ断れないし だからその彼女は編んで
そこはつなげて ああ よくできたんだと
じゃあ首にかけてみようと
で 首にかけてみたらと
首にかけたんです 首にかけた瞬間であれは金になってしまったんです
それをお坊さんが自分の罪悪を持っていたんだから
それは先にも何も言ってないんですね
もう泣いて泣いて これ見切りがないんですね
で いなくなって あれは子供は当然すごく喜んだし
奥さんの方が何とも言う言葉がなくてね
もう黙って待っていたんだけど
子供はそこですごく楽しく遊んでるんですね
そこをどう見たっても
それ最高作品なんですよ
これ自然の藁そのままに金になったんだから
人間には手ではできるもんじゃないんですね
いくらもうすごい職人であろうと
これ難しい そこであなた方にはこんなものあるはずがないんだと
これは王様の財産で 王様にしかそんな優れた職人がいるわけがないんだということで泥棒扱いされちゃったんです
泥棒扱いされて まあ即席に決めちゃってね
その家の旦那を でもそちらにももう何も言うことできないんですね
誰も信じませんだからね
そんなことあるんだと
現代人はよく信じますね
そういう物質的現象化で
昔の人はあまり信じませんでしたけどね
いっぱいあった時代でね
ただ そこをすごくまた察して
このお坊さんがね まあ証人として行ったんです
大変なことでしたからね
でも悪気が作ってあげたんですよと言っちゃったら
これ戒律違反でしょうと
人殺りとか殺害があったら言えませんだからね
そこでこれをまあ一応これお坊さんもこうやったんであって
話は言ってるんだけど
向こうも信じませんね
それはありえないと その時限って王様にあんたどう思いますかね？あんたのこの柱とかね
金建物が 気になったらどう思いますかね？とか言ったら
気になったらきれいでしょうと言った途端
全部金になっちゃったんです
そしたらお坊さんの方驚いちゃって
やっぱりこれはお坊さんの力でこの新郎さんにあげたプレゼントだよと
そしたらまあ何のことのないと言ってお坊さんが帰ると
あの柱は元に戻ったんだけど
で そこは分かりませんだけど
本当にこの物質を変えるか
あるいは人の認識能力変えるか
どっちかとはっきりは分かりませんですけど
人の認識能力変えたっていうのは同じこと
だからこの世の中っていうのはほとんど幻惑だから
金だと映ると金なんです
そのものは金になる必要はないんで
食べ物も同じでしょ 美味しいと思ったら美味しいんだから
日本だったらね 醤油とか味噌とかすごい美味しく感じるでしょうね
我々インド系統の人々にとっては塩味しか感じないんです
だから塩は何が美味しいかと
我々思ったりするんです
でも皆様方はこんな辛いものは何が美味しいかと思ったりするでしょうね
でも私たちにとっては辛い香辛料が入っているものは美味しいという感覚が確実
美味しいと思える 皆様にはお醤油と砂糖とまあなんとかなんとか出汁を入れて作ったものがすごく美味しいと
と感じちゃうんですよ
ですから 思えばただそれだけのことなんです
実際に味噌が美味しいか
インドのカレーの方が美味しいか
誰が分かったもんですか
それは誰も分かったもんじゃないです
そういうことだから 人生っていう場合もね
まあどっちかもあれば自分でもいいんだけどね
認識変えるかね ものを変えるかっていうことしかありませんですけど
まあそういうふうな とにかくそういうちょっとちょっといろいろヒストリカルとかね
ありますけど まあやっぱりそういうことをやって認識を得て
すごく仲良くして収入を得ようと
そこで生活させようということは禁止なんですね
だからあのお坊さんはものすごい貧しくて
たったガラスで作った腕輪ぐらいでも買ってあげることもできない家でご飯食べていたんだから
そのそれからその家でご飯食べていたということで
お坊さんは大変喜んで
やっぱり信仰ある人々って素晴らしい
あなた方は大変羨ましいということで
もう財産をあげたいんですけれど
時計にしようとしたところで
まあこうやってこの生活は清らかな生活の中に入ったんですよ
そこは三番目の戒律ですね
で それはそれ パッキャサンニクシラ
これ五番 四番 で これは最近にはあまり関係ないでしょうと思いますけどね
これは出家には厳密に戒律なんですね
食べるものには執着しないで食べなさいと
食べるものを見て あ これはもうすぐ切っ-